are we live how do we be in uh I do we
go to hire do we keep the energy up I
said we played in the middle right in
the middle or in the middle so no I was
trying to take my halo and then my
volume came low
halo
welcome to Feb bring it down I don't
know from the top seas yeah I don't want
to come across too like yeah welcome to
Fatman beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
barnard Hey hi
slow news week slow news year yeah
nothing nothing noteworthy has happened
kids I before we take a step forward
first off our hearts go out to the
family friends loved ones of George
Floyd that's at the epicenter of all
this of course it goes beyond that as
we're seeing and whatnot
but you know as the world today
reflected pent up rage justifiable rage
as the world burned today it didn't seem
like a great idea to come talk about
comic book movies and the Snyder cut and
stuff like that so I reached out to mark
and I was like do we do this
and as I tweeted for those who maybe
didn't see it sweet mark whose get you
got a computer near you read the words
exactly because mark got big kudos they
were like he's such a good writer and I
had to read that over and over again
yeah he is but like come on but this my
tweet he's got a friend marks yeah the
thing my tweet but mark his quote of my
tweet give yourself a JC shot if you
will JC ladies and gentlemen uh okay
let's see you tweet a lot okay
with all that's happening right now I
felt it felt trivial to do Fatman beyond
so I asked mark barnard and for his take
and he said quote I do your best mark
like don't hold your nail don't do an
impression Fox okay I think it might be
important to do a show addressing both
the things that are tearing us apart as
well as the things that bring us
together so yeah so we're here tonight
because mark said something very
eloquent and very true I mean it's lucky
wasn't a gift or an emoji you so bear
with us the show is gonna go places
today but we only came here tonight
because I put up that tweet and I was
like look thoughts
what is everyone feeling and
overwhelmingly people were like listen
to mark smart one why would you ever
question mark so we're here tonight
because the folks at home asked us to be
here tonight ladies and gentlemen and we
will we'll have a chat and whatnot
you've been staying off Twitter I have
yeah Twitter and and Instagram have been
you know at some time sources of both
information and respite and joy but all
too often especially this last week it's
been paying and it's been a kind of pain
that personally you know it's important
that we saw the footage of mr. Floyd
being killed being murdered by my police
officers but seeing it over and over and
over again even with the best of
intentions even with the best of like
this can't happen again just as for
George like all of that stuff and I
understand it I get what people are
feeling by sharing it
but ingesting those images got to be
painful after
and if it was the only time that the
sort of thing had happened it would be
like an isolated occurrence okay we'll
just move on but it's it seems to have
been the overriding you know
meta-narrative or one meta-narrative
over the last ten years yeah has been
you know with frightening regularity
here is footage of an african-american
usually man being killed by police or at
the very least being killed by somebody
pretending to Authority that have been
captured on a you know body cam or cell
phone footage or or whatever and the and
not to say that it's commodification
because I don't think anybody making
money off of this but I think there is
this this regularization this
nominalization this idea that this is
just the way things are yeah the
normalization of this that after a while
just you know it it chips away at the
armor that at least I have to put on
every day going on into the world and
it's you know I mean the armor if just
for you personally just for me
personally like its you know it's it is
a concept that I think that most African
Americans are incredibly familiar with
and most white Americans are not is the
idea that that walking through the world
carries for me a level of endurance that
I think it might not carry for for my
white counterparts simply because you
know there is apparently an incredibly
legitimate chance that for no good
reason of my own I could be like walking
my dog or like taking pictures of bird
in Central Park and somebody calls a cop
on me because they don't like a thing
that I said there was I just read a
statistic today and I can't even quote
what it is so this is specious at best
but still sobering one in 1000 black men
will be killed by it's it's something
like you know a hundred and seventy one
percent more likely for it to happen to
me that it'll happen to you
sort of I mean look when I saw the
footage it's horrifying
you know like everyone else you're going
get up get off get get stop but then I
it's not contextualizing
compartmentalised but as horrified as
i'm as a human being there is a remove
for me so for you it gets to a play a
point of like there is no removal you
see George Floyd you see you I see me I
see my dad I see my kid like I see you
know most of the people that I grew up
with and it's you know and you have to
you have to build up some kind of callus
to that right like because you have to
go out into the world you gotta go do
your job and you got to be you know the
kind of person who can earn the kind of
money that will provide for your family
you've got to be you've got to be a
human being in the world and with that
comes a certain amount of just being
able to absorb the things the world
throws at you and like I don't complain
about it because there's no alternative
to it you know it just is what it is and
you know explaining explaining to people
what that feels like it's difficult
because there's no context for it and
we're talking to somebody about the idea
that America and forgive me guys but
America is a racist country and I'll say
well I'm not racist like now and I'm not
saying you are
I'm saying that it's a racist country
and racism not being used as simply not
liking one person because of the color
of their skin but racism as an economic
system in the same way that America is
also a capitalist country and like when
you were born you never chose to be a
capitalist right no America just happens
to be capitalist sure and you benefit
from that economic system and as such
like you even if there was no moral
attachment to it you would call yourself
a capitalist whether or not you own a
business whether or not you are in the
stock market whatever it is she's the
person who goes through a job yeah it's
like well America is also a racist
country and that it was a country built
on you know and like for legit built on
the idea that we are going to have a
labor force that works for us for free
and part of being able to wrap our heads
around it came the subjugation of those
people because otherwise how could you
look at yourself in the mirror and
having taken advantage of
vast swathes of people in such a way and
that has been the economic base from
which a country is built and so it's
built into the DNA of America and it
still is there you know and when you
watch things on the news like riots in
in Minneapolis riots in Los Angeles
Riots in Atlanta and you and you wonder
like how could this be why are people of
this angry and then you look at you know
white dudes with guns going into state
capitals demanding that you know we
lower the quarantine because I want to
go to the nail salon and those people
with guns who show up in the government
buildings don't get tear-gassed you know
they don't get beaten they don't get
marched away they're just clearly you
deserve to be here whereas people
beginning peaceful protests and you know
I am as horrified as anybody else is at
what those protests turn into you know
is one today there's I walked up Fairfax
and CN la cienega went to Beverly Hills
mm-hmm
there's footage of people on Rodeo Drive
20,000 people I think I read kneeling in
protests mm-hmm
bodies everywhere but nobody beaten
anybody and then the reports are that
the police showed up and that's when
that's when it gets faster like an and
it's also unclear who within those
20,000 people are burning things and
breaking things and smashing they
weren't even doing that on Rodeo Drive
it was literally looked like a sit-in
like in this was live wasn't just a
photos like somebody was tweeting it and
that was they and then they were saying
you know within the next ten minutes the
cops showed up and all hell broke loose
yeah you know and it's while I can't say
it is not for me to condone or not like
I don't have authority to condone
anything but I understand the the anger
you know and I understand that the anger
is compounded by the fact that we are
all still wrestling with kovat you know
with which is its own thing
I literally forgot suddenly yeah that
was not in that wasn't the top news
story and for the first time in a long
time a long time now but and that's the
other thing it's like it's deceptive
because you're like alright this is the
story now and now you start going like
well that's clearly not as big a
conflagration let's deal with this but
we forget that right you know and and
it's still get infected and it's also it
doesn't go unnoticed that the president
is more than happy for us not to be
talking about a hundred thousand deaths
in America he is more than happy to say
those thugs and you know when the
looting starts the shooting starts
because that will exacerbate what's
happening because it does not seem to be
within him to find a way to unify he
just continues to divide for his own
personal gain sorry gang don't mean to
be political but the world's on fire
so why not talk about it you know and so
the fact that like yes every sometimes
it feels like every other week with
frightening regularity we get footage of
somebody being killed by the police that
hadn't always led to riots you know and
riots / rebellions call it what you will
but there is this quote that I've been
seeing floating around a lot from our
Luther King which is a riot is the
scream of the unheard in that that is
how you get people to take notice of you
like they're not going to give you
anything for free you have to find a way
to force them to action and riot is the
way the disenfranchised do that on a
larger scale neither here nor there but
you know there has been a series of
events like this that haven't prompted
this kind of violence but also you have
colvett on top of it which is affecting
the african-american community at a
deeper rate than it affects almost
anybody else except for Native Americans
and that can also be traced along like
income lines and in income inequality
lines and who has access to medical care
who has access to to goods and services
that should be part of the government
and what they you know Oh to you as a
citizen who pays taxes and so all of
those things together you know all of
those it's it's this this melting pot
ironically of fury and this is what
happens when it bubbles over
and and it's and so to see this coming
in and to see this on my timeline and
you know to see and another part of the
frustration is and and you know I not to
make it any more racial than it already
is but there are tons of white folks on
my timeline who I love deeply and then
tons who I just don't know it all just
filtering through who are again like
justice for George Floyd you know
whatever and like donating money and I
get it and I get it
but this isn't a new occurrence like
it's not as if we suddenly knew that
this was a thing that happened to two
african-americans more that happened to
anybody else
and so the the hurt comes from are we
going to forget this again like is this
just a thing to put on your timeline
because it feels like it's a thing that
should be on your timeline or is it a
I'm actually going to remember this when
it comes time to vote I'm gonna remember
this when it comes time to look at these
down ballot you know who's the sheriff
of my town who will be in this
particular role until he gets fired or
dead is it a lifetime appointment what's
that guy's policies like how does he
feel about
militarizing the police how does he feel
about overreach you know looking at you
know from tip to stern like president
all the way down like that's that is
technically when we have our chance to
effect change and the past three and a
half years has not been overwhelmingly
robust in the we're not happy with the
way things are so it's all of that anger
and it's all of that frustration and
it's all of that like you know my mother
will you know call me up and like you
know and I think a lot of people's
mothers do this it's like I thought that
we dealt with this in the 60s so weird
you said that I asked Jen's dad my
father-in-law
Byron mmm lovely dude you know I said
you you were around in the 60s was this
as bad as it was then as is now and he
was like oh no and he was like in law
enforcement he was like no he's like
this I've never seen anything like this
yeah I used to kind of take comfort
going like wow you know this country
went through
upheaval in the 60s and survived and to
hear somebody who was there go like not
the same thing like its kind of scary
scary times were living in yeah you know
and it's and I wouldn't alive in the 60s
don't know what it's like but you know
there there is enough information both
anecdotal and legitimate that supports
the idea that it was always bad the only
thing to change is that everybody has a
camera now like everybody can document
it everybody can see it and it's easy to
to read about it and you know that the
story and the ninth page of the paper
but like seeing somebody's life get
choked at seeing a twelve-year-old get
shot in the back seeing seeing seeing
over and over again it's hard to forget
and that is that is I think what most
people are hoping that doesn't happen
again is like let's not forget this
happens all the time
you know the coroner report comes in
like oh we can't actually support the
charge of murder because apparently
there were others della mints and it's
like no dude he's yeah you know it's
like and so this this is a flare-up of
anger and frustration and and to certain
degree lack of faith and we're up though
that we haven't I've never seen anything
like it you I mean I haven't seen
anything like riots like it you know
talks about 92 they had riots here yeah
I mean it yeah but the LA riots are the
the Rodney King riots this is happening
like everywhere yeah I mean it it I mean
Ferguson also blew up in a big bad way
that moved beyond Ferguson and Sur to
swell all over the country and and major
urban centers get it more than anybody
else does Atlanta New York Chicago LA
but I think that you know like I said it
compounded with the fact that we're all
enduring an ongoing American trauma you
know and the the inequality even of that
trauma and that's all that this is at
its core is like hey maybe don't kill me
so much you know like maybe treat me
like you treat everybody else like it's
just equality nobody wants like
nobody's out for advantage like this
isn't to like gain territory it's just
hey maybe maybe let's look real hard at
how we trained police officers let's
look really hard and how we do things
like grant mortgages and you know extend
unemployment benefits and and health
insurance and all of those things that
will help people not feel so much as if
they're just barely holding on so that
one thing is there to tip them over the
edge but you know like all of this
happened like I have been avoiding the
news as well because it's you know I
also have but so much tolerance for all
right--let's the mayor's gonna tell us
again how bad that kovat figures are but
you know we're looking at reopening
stuff and it just gets to be a steady
march of information yeah that doesn't
change very much the narrative doesn't
change very much but then I found myself
watching the SpaceX launch today and you
know oh how nice are you [ __ ] writing
son of a [ __ ] did you know this whole
time you're like I'm gonna take it real
and then I'm gonna take it real
inspirational I'm gonna take it to space
oh my god right up into the heaven I saw
that it was right I mean I sound stupid
to say but it felt rather soaring to see
it I rolled it tear because nine years
it's been nine years since Americans
launched an American into space from
American soil and you know it's been
what 45 years since we went to the moon
but whatever but even still like that's
huge and massive and you know
inspirational even though I hated all
the music they played during the launch
and like guys ease up on the Vangelis I
get it it's awesome you know but at the
same token I found myself both like I
rolled a tear because if we launched a
dude into space again that's [ __ ]
awesome but then I'm like but we didn't
do it
Elon Musk did oh come on man and that
helped NASA NASA NASA but um but I'm
like and the president shows up and give
us a big round of applause I'm like yeah
but America used to do this a mer
they used to do this yeah I didn't quite
follow the story what it did space I
mean a sex it's their rocket ship like
their money like they spent like they've
been spending ten years refining how to
launch people into space and NASA has
given up doing that so the what I read
sorry I'm just gonna jump Jesse Capen is
that NASA was excited that a company
like SpaceX is doing the kind of grunt
work of putting people in space that can
be profit driven because now NASA can
focus on space missions that are that no
company would ever do because they're
not profit driven they can focus on
exploration doing a more Star Trek like
for the betterment of mankind mission
and SpaceX can send astronauts with
supplies up to the space station because
they can make money off of that mm-hmm
yeah but like in in the same breath this
is the president who's like the post
office doesn't work we have to abolish
it because I can't figure out what it a
way to make money it's like dude if if
profit is the way that you want to pull
this you know country out of you know
whatever the hell scape it's in now
can't NASA make a profit on hiking space
[ __ ] into space yeah like and if you
can't do that I don't understand it and
I remembered Neil deGrasse Tyson you
know years ago saying that if you like
it was 1/2 of a cent of every tax dollar
went to NASA then you could fund space
travel for the next 50 years and they
couldn't manage to squeeze out of half a
penny for the future and so we now have
to cede that future to people like Elon
Musk and you know good bad indifferent I
don't know if he's had his Tony Stark
transition yet or if he's now like if he
used to preach like sliver in the heart
Tony Stark or the post like I built the
Iron Man suit and flew into the desert
Tony Stark who needs a cheeseburger and
wants to abandon his evil ways Tony
Stark
don't know yet but is he even Tony Stark
he was always like I remember reading
that that was kind of the model for how
they were envisioning the current Tony
Stark like Favreau back at the gym
really
yes like he's he's the closest person on
earth we have to that it was like in on
mosque and Bill Gates and Steve Jobs but
the the tech billionaire visionary but
Tony Stark's vision happened to be in
weapons and so of course he had to shift
that to this rocket here works though it
works so that takes Elon Musk one step
closer to Tony Stark it really does and
like it was super inspirational and like
lovely and wonderful and here's what
here's what a UH some mark about it
though you're like its it was super
inspirational but man why did they have
to [ __ ] have SpaceX again always
something it's over something with me
but yeah like it's it is the you know
it's what's next like what's next is the
thing that drives us as a as a people as
a society as a world you know what's the
next thing that we get to conquer you
know space space were you know we're
explorers at heart and so the the fact
that we had abandoned that version of
exploration was a little sad to me you
know it's nice that I get to work in a
Star Trek show which is all about like
the joy and wonder of exploring space
let's be honest today's special effects
it's better to watch it do it nothing up
there of Klingons know nothing man let
the closer the more dudes we like hurl
into orbit the closer we are to the
Whalley future we actually really want
your [ __ ] true chairs floating around
on chair sipping cupcakes out of straws
who's watching my movies on my magic
motorized chair before we began the show
ladies and gentlemen we were trying to
figure out what the structure of the
show would be and we were talking about
like do we do Q&A tonight at all didn't
seem like kind of night to do QA and the
two sample questions I threw out that we
might get like there's a question mama
be like Kevin and Mark how do you fix
this and I'd be like as a channel my
inner Obama
speech then we talked about the second
question would be dear Kevin and Mark
how would Batman fix this and that's
what made mark to figure it out that's
the problem here yeah you know like his
Batman honestly he's spending all his
money on tumblers and caves that like
only like four or five dudes are gonna
go into and not like you know school
systems and you know the systemic
support marginal thing if he would just
invest in infrastructure he wouldn't
have to beat up so many people like you
can't actually fight crime by literally
fighting crime imma punch it in the face
a lot like again attractive I suppose
not effective I'm sure somebody would
argue like he does that already but he's
still gonna fight crime like well let me
see the paperwork come back yeah
actually how many more school lunches
goody buy if he doesn't have to buy
another tumblr one [ __ ] you know
Batarang yeah what does that cost I mean
as we discovered he's gotta like import
this [ __ ] through black-market companies
from like either he'd or an old British
man hand making like he can't have
somebody manufacture it he's gotta make
it himself
yeah you know I gotta build a bat jet
you could or how about a bunch of school
buses he said yeah but I know you know
what if follow me on this guy in a mask
takes over the city with a nuke I'll
need a plan yeah look like a lobster an
angry black lobster floating around
Pittsburgh I tell you what I'll build
you your fleet of buses if a they're all
black be the shape of bass you see I can
remote-control them when I need them to
do some [ __ ] for me yes kids on their
way to school bus self-destruct mode
activated
I need the bat bus pod yes Batman would
not have a solution for this you know
what's in there that great as a now
sketch about when Batman goes to like a
dinner party and he runs into some dude
who got beaten up by Batman
no they did a sketch couple years ago
and it was like Bennet yeah he was Bruce
Wayne and the idea was like food
giveaway at Wayne Manor and [ __ ]
people coming in or like you know my dad
got beat up by Batman and like it was
like a really violent unnecessary oh but
surely he learned his lesson now he
can't walk back is broken so now I was
like a meth addict uh you know help with
the pain order kept coming in as a Chris
Pratt is the new guy he was just like
y'all talk about Batman to my homies my
homies they just walking down the street
Batman swung out of the sky punch him in
the face and snap his kneecaps Oh Batman
would never do that clearly he must have
no mames coming back from his day job at
7-eleven if that man just annihilated
his spine Oh was it Melissa Billy she
comes in and she was doing like like a
Puerto Rican accent she's like y'all
talking about Batman and she goes I hear
the Joker's got a plan to cut off his
wiener I was like what hold on that's a
good sketch like a Thanksgiving sketch
no wait turkeys or something like that
if I remember yeah it's good um all
right Wow so yeah the world is on fire
it is um you know how does one how do we
how do what do we do I mean I think that
that so much of it involves education
and information and some acknowledgement
of both privilege and responsibility
that comes with privilege and realizing
that the narrative that we have all sort
of come to learn and know about America
it's not necessarily the truth of what
it is now to say that it's fake news and
they're gonna do that I'm just gonna say
that America paints a picture of itself
to make itself feel better yeah and we
occasionally get to witness the attempts
at rewriting that picture you know not
long ago there were like Texas schools
maybe or some school system in the South
that wanted to have in the in the social
studies textbooks that the Civil War was
not about slavery and it's like no you
can't do that because that's what it was
like that legit is fact and trying to
rewrite that is dangerous
and and I know that things like that
have been rewritten because it was
wasn't very long ago that I discovered
that the Statue of Liberty was not about
immigration the Statue of Liberty was
literally a present present from the
French in the late 1800s recognizing the
end of slavery like there are chains at
her feet and broken bonds and it was all
about you know give us your like like
your your your humbled mass in order to
breathe for free like it's about slavery
and it's about the freedom of slavery
and America does its best to pretend
that that was never part of its own
history but the more we acknowledge that
that's what we are the quicker we can
find a path towards being something
better and that is I think what at least
I hope comes from events like this is
that we all kind of look at ourselves
and and and our perspectives on the
world and find where we're wanting and
where we're lacking and change and
demand change and you know there's
there's ways to demand it that require
legislation and campaigning and
donations and all of that stuff and then
there's ways that require blood sadly
those are the ones that managed to get
the most things done especially in
America you know like change is an awful
ugly thing and there's almost always a
price to be paid and from the very
beginning of America like somebody's got
a bleed for it and you know all too
often it is people who look like me so
I'd love it if we could find the way to
the other change so that people who look
like me don't have to put on that armor
every day going into the world that's
generous I thought you were like let's
flip it so people are like you have to
deal with this I'm like well I mean I'm
sure there are other ways but yeah again
it's my right all that anybody wants is
equality nobody wants supremacy and the
hardest thing in the world is to take
supremacy from people who already have
it so yeah let's just do better and open
our eyes and remember the things we see
when they're open I'm so sorry for you
my friend on it I've never even thought
about that aspect of like
you know like the extra [ __ ] step it
takes to leave the house like you know
no matter where I was in life or like
you know I grew up poor so I understand
that having [ __ ] I was fat so I
understand people being like you're an
outsider but I'm nothing ever made me
scared for my life to leave the house
like ever in this in this world even in
a blackout where all the lights went out
[ __ ] when I was a kid like nothing there
was fires down the street from us I've
never been afraid to leave my house just
because because I'm white I guess
something that goes through on some
level goes through your head all the
time you know it goes through your head
in the same way that like gravity goes
through your head and that you know that
if you trip and you fall you're gonna
hurt yourself
like you don't think about it it doesn't
necessarily stop you from doing things
but it's it is more painful when you
realize that no matter what I do what I
achieve how much money I make how many
TV shows I work on how many Twitter
followers I have how many people listen
to a podcast as wonderful and glorious
as all those things are that will not
stop that from happening to me
because that is never going to be part
of the narrative of here's why I shot
this dude because they won't know any of
those things there is there is a fear
that has been built in both systemic and
sometimes personal that is completely
overrides apparently any logical
threat-assessment like I am scary so I
got to do a thing you know and it
doesn't matter anything about my life
that that's a possibility every day and
you have to push through and you have to
find a way to just conduct yourself in
the world that doesn't you know
Bulai that much pain because nobody
wants to live like that
nobody wants to live afraid and I don't
but I live aware which is a different
thing what do you tell your kids
especially in the midst of this um you
know they've grown up in a world that
like you said last ten years this is
unfortunately like a regular occurrence
and that's why we're seeing yeah I mean
it people react right now
it's the it's the hardest part of being
that kind of parent which is I wish I
didn't have to tell you that you can't
wear a hoodie but I have to tell you
that like I wish I had to I wish I
didn't have to sit down and tell you
like I know I'm a just did a dumb
teenage thing and you just like you did
a stupid thing at school and you you
quote unquote quote
you stole a sandwich because you didn't
have time to bite it was like yeah I get
it innocent crime you know to the other
dudes who might be on your water club
water polo team it's fine but for you
wait a second mmm who's on a water polo
team like it really it does your kids
got a [ __ ] horse
and it's a aqua horse sea horse
Ozzy oh my God he's like Aquaman and all
those old 70s seventies drawings did he
do it in the movie as well you did you
rode two sharks I believe never a
seahorse I think it Meera she rather
severs yeah I get that movie was long
but there were so much movie there's a
lot of there's so much like I can't take
all of this into my brain I got a ring
consume it man it was [ __ ] like
powerful it was a lot going on all right
wait yeah so it's the like you just
understand that you will be judged on a
different scale than the rest of your
friends and you need to be aware of that
and and the the second third fourth
fifth shots that some of your friends
might take to get into trouble are not
available to you you know and I know you
don't hear and I know you don't want to
start living your life this way and I
don't want that for you either but you
need to be aware of it that in the world
that this is a thing that you need to
deal with and I hope it never comes up I
know but never happens but it might and
you need to know why I mean George foot
bless you you're right that what kind of
sneeze is that Jay see you might want to
put that mask back on the you know the
George Floyd story begins with a like
crime no greater than musically writing
a bad check writing is that what it was
a check that's what I'd heard it was
either a bad check or like a counter bad
- honey I've read that it was like a bad
20 or something
and you know I can't imagine anyone
thought that's where it would lead now
like the the truth of it is for all of
these crimes which you know at best or
misdemeanors
you know the sentence for those crimes
should a not be death and B be carried
out in a court of law
and not on the streets of whatever city
that we're in right you know and the the
difference between those lives the
difference between you know just being
able to kind of just live your life like
Footloose and fancy-free and always
having to what wonder did the dumb
[ __ ] thing I did ten minutes ago
sentenced me to death you know and it's
it's hard and it's tough and and the
fact that the only thing that is keeping
some people like there was footage a
couple days ago which I chuckled that
but I shouldn't have because it was kind
of tragic of you know the police rollin
up on some homeless guy I want to say
was unlike Hollywood Boulevard or Santa
Monica whatever and Denzel Washington
like gets out of his car to kind of like
mediate this situation because Denzel
our greatest actor you know legit was
like if in a minute this could go south
and like this dude is clearly homeless
and in distress is going to say the
wrong thing and these officers may or
may not do the wrong thing but maybe
they won't if I'm here and so I'm going
to kind of get out of my car stuck on my
mask on but you can tell us Denzel
because he walks like Denzel like he's
just stalking it even sister like this
yeah footage you like that is Denzel
[ __ ] Denzel Washington I run first
name basis over here yeah you know I'm
on the email list but like that's that's
a thing that Denzel Denzel privilege
lets him do that and so you know the the
thing that that I think that I think a
lot of african-americans have understood
and and younger ones are wrestling with
is that we actually can't enforce this
change like this change you know you can
only put out the fire from within the
house
and it falls on you know it falls on
white America to fix white America
because the problem doesn't actually
reside in black America
it's what how far is too far how far is
it that that you know your average white
person won't accept this and only until
we reach that point will change actually
happen and I'd like to hope we're there
I would have liked to hope we were there
like 10 years ago but if this is the
moment awesome
hope so fires fingers crossed
JC can you turn that down we're hearing
ourselves all right we I mean I I am out
of things to say um
I mean I I'm not but what really and
that's the last episode of batman beyond
final word um no I mean it's and that
again I'm speaking for me like I think
that if you speak to speak for a lot of
people mark you know I I don't know it's
what's going on in my heart so what's
going on in my head I hope that
everybody's safe I hope that you and
yours are safe I hope that that
everybody can can push through this with
a modicum of self-respect by the end I
don't in any way mean to be like the
respectability police and you know
there's ways to do this I don't know
those ways and if you're joining the
protests be very careful if you were
going to a city to support the protest
that's admirable
don't go someplace and be violent
there's a lot of footage of the kids
with skateboards just bustin cop car
windows yeah like not white kids with
skate police like if you're going to
join the protest like yeah be there with
the protesters don't ya don't turn it
into something yes like don't be the
reason why the news says this protest
turned violent because like I'm just a
white dude is looking for a reasonably
some [ __ ] up and I got to set some fires
and I get to I I tell you man some of
the footage I saw was like like I
whenever I watch Law & Order and you
know
[ __ ] the two cops go talk to some
potential witness and like I got time
for you I'm like what [ __ ] world do
these if a cop ever came to talk to me
I'd be like I'll tell you everything
I'll tell you [ __ ] I did when I was six
years old like you got me like very
little fear to the police on on Law &
Order what were we just talking about
I felt the white kids of skateboards
some watching the footage of like bunch
of protesters attacking I guess a Chase
Bank but they had a bunch of police
inside the bank
like in position with weapons I don't
know akan but like ready maybe just
batons definitely shields waiting for
them to come through and there was a
this white guy with a skateboard that
just kept like bashing the window with
the skateboard and like would scream at
them and then come up bash and police
would brace and like I it just that
seemed privileged that's that's a dude
who's not afraid yeah if the cops are
gonna kill him I watched the footage I
was like I would I couldn't be that
person but yeah this dude apparently was
just like they're not gonna shoot me
and he just kept like hitting the glass
in front of the police yeah it's like
sometimes when you look at the at the
riot footage you like this looks less
like a riot and more like this Celtics
won a championship and I'm like this is
Boston on fire in celebration
you know Pittsburgh or like you know
pick a predominantly white city that
wins a championship and shits on fire
just a way they just took down isn't it
Phillip Philadelphia the Rizzo statue
mmm that's what I saw before I left to
come here they're burning that down he
burned down a statue takes a lot yeah
you gotta be patient
so yeah just and and be careful and be
mindful of the fact that even though you
as a citizen want to let your voice be
heard and want to help signal blue stuff
these remember that there is somebody of
darker skin
who has seen and live those pictures a
thousand times so you know maybe we are
past the sharing video of atrocities and
maybe we're closer to the let's actually
making sure these atrocities happen far
far less powerful words my friends all I
got so it's all we needed there it is
that's the important part of the show
now let's talk about HBO max up a couple
days ago that's all the show is gonna be
he was like I watch the major BMX
markets like I can't wait if I could
talk about HP and the world kind of
exploded we get to the trivial part of
the show now ladies and gentlemen the
reason that we gather every week mark
here used to be a new zone and he
tracked down the news and guess what he
still tracks down the news meaning he
bug it does a Google search before we
get here yeah and the first item was
just I subscribed to a thing that
apparently already got for free and just
looked at it for a little bit the
accident of discovery yes so mark dug up
the news so let's do the news let's do
the news the unimportant news it is the
like if the world is getting too much
for you and you want to disconnect you
turn to as we all have done for the last
three months in quarantine con Netflix
Oh net content media entertainer and the
latest giant Botev of content to come
down the river is HBO max now I had what
on my phone HBO now or something like
that not the one that come on my cable
channel but the one on the app that I
paid for I think it was HBO now HBO now
is the one you paid for if you didn't
have HBO all right if you had HBO you
got HBO GO
I love that app it was so wonderful
clean you knew where everything was and
stuff and it was just all classy HBO
even stuff on HBO one that quote classy
just easy to navigate everything in its
place everything under that title made
sense because it's like HBO now and it's
like this these were all home box office
then right this is all [ __ ] that HBO is
either original series or stuff that is
on their air
some way max on the other hand has
something of an identity issue it it
does and it because again you have
Direct TV which is under the HBO like
Warner Brothers AT&T media whatever silo
then like H all the HBO's and then just
like the other Rando stuff that Warner
Brothers has sort of the rights to like
they've got hubs if you if you scroll
down to the bottom of your HP on max
page like oh alright here's our content
hubs and like TCM like Turner Classic
Movies is a hub and she'll be DC's a hub
studio ghibli is a hub all about
miyazaki movies Sesame Street is a hub
Sesame Street is a hub Looney Tunes yeah
okay cool this is awesome I suppose and
you start like digging through those
hubs and you're kind of like there's not
a ton here like especially DC like I
poked through there and I'm like oh okay
well you've got the Justice League's
you've got this night over stuff and
you've got all of the the sort of Burton
you know Schumacher verse Batman things
and you've got a couple of Batman movies
like return of the Joker Batman Beyond
another Joker problem like where's
where's Batman the Animated Series like
where's Batman Beyond where's Justice
League where's where are they yeah I
other is it because they've got them on
the DC app or I think they're licensed I
think it's one of those like you know
Warner Brothers all of their media silos
don't quite play as nicely with each
other as say Disney's do so like
Disney's God Marvel and Pixar and you
know there are classic animated stuff
and like okay ya know those old Star
Wars sure we got everything and DC and
more brothers like well we used to do
licensed stuff out and you know that'll
be on this app for awhile Netflix has
this and maybe this is on Hulu now or
and so it's made for something of a
scattershot experience where like
there's a lot there but not quite what
do you expect to be there at least if
you're if you're a nerd you're like okay
cool all the Harry Potter's are here
that's great they would have they they
needed those to launch they needed us to
launch jewels in the crown totally and
like alright
all the Lord the Rings are here okay
cool I get that oh I guess they would
need those too
yeah but like none of the Berlin TV
shows are there because they're all
under license to Netflix like Netflix
has they're on dub wait they're on The
WB but Warner Brothers produces those
shows mm-hmm so by rights they should
well not by write by logic by rights
goddammit like they have Batwoman but
they don't have the flash they don't
have black lightning they don't have
I've checked out a Batwoman on the HBO
max it's as purple as this jacket that
it really is that's I like the it
reminds me of the old classic HBO like
Big Finish man it was a groovy like
depending on what it was right yeah and
like meanwhile you were soaring over
that like kind of model City and then
the HBO turns into a star and then comes
out it's super [ __ ] awesome whoever
[ __ ] did that man like I hope they're
proud that like years later middle-aged
man to know it a note for know various I
expect every sunset to have the HBO look
with the middle exactly but yeah like
it's just it it feels rushed and I don't
think it is but it feels that way it
feels like they they saw Disney Plus
coming down the pike and they saw
Netflix making gains where's ours
where's ours and they saw peacock you
know beginning and like it it it doesn't
really have like a killer original to
launch with I mean they we've been
talking for you know a year about all
the acquisitions that they'd made and I
we got this in production we're doing
this we're doing a Snider cut we're
doing and I'm a venire they don't have a
Mandalorian you know like there have a
lot what's they're Mandalorian a love
life I think so look in Anna Kendrick
show yeah that was their big last series
launched there was there and they were
supposed to have a friends reunion
special that they couldn't shoot because
of physical
virus and it's like in friends is the
big marquee like all of the friends here
and that's kind of what HP L max is the
friends that for a lot of people right
yeah I mean I was not me but I know and
also like if I need a friend's fix it's
still on the regular television like
every morning is it really like hours of
it like it's Seinfeld and friends and
Nick at night and he's like built
themselves on oh my god it's the new
Lucy it's Lucy you can never not see
your friends you know and I wanted I
wanted like I saw the Looney Tunes stuff
I'm like awesome I'm gonna watched one
of the Looney Tunes you were the new one
I watched duck amuck which was you know
classic sit course and I was looking for
what's opera doc another classic not on
there I'm like how do you it's a way
they had dug him up but not what's up or
Doc yeah cut the cord the look at snappy
that's all I you know I don't know that
I would have me and I know me I probably
would have gotten it regardless but I'll
be honest with you it felt like a gift
on my phone because like all the sudden
like what the [ __ ] what happened to my
HBO in the mic they weren't real clear
how they were gonna launch so like at
the end of the day doesn't cost me
anything more and stuff and I've already
got it
so I'm okay with it but it is a it's not
a deep hole yet you know the idea of it
being rushed
I got cosine sounds like they were like
well we do that everybody's doing it we
got do it we got some stuff let's put up
an app and it's not quite what Apple was
cuz Apple Apple never even pretended we
were gonna have a library they were just
like no we're gonna offer you like you
know these doesn't crazy [ __ ]
expensive shows with movie stars in it
and maybe that'll be enough to justify
the app we gave you for free because you
own an Apple thing I believe their
policy if you ever read that long
[ __ ] small print that's exactly what
Mark said he memorized here yeah so like
you look at Apple TV you're like yeah
whatever I mean sure and I may never go
to this but I'm going to use this
service
I watched servant oh yeah as an M night
Shyamalan show I just finished watching
and
defending Jacob with America with a
Steve Rogers Steve Rogers himself
I asked me and my wife they weekly on an
app on Apple plus they don't do like
here's the dump [ __ ] off go enjoy
yourself they like come back every we
like old STIs and [ __ ] so we've been old
season at watching the defending Jacob
and I've been bitter about it every week
like why don't they just put a [ __ ]
thing in and so we were watching it
tonight is the last episode like pickets
eight episodes it's done but finally
after eight episodes I was like you know
she don't go for the Marvel movies not
like she's like [ __ ] him but she's like
you go you know she's going what are
their names
Iron Man Superman Batman call me when it
all changes so he's too many man I got
one man in my life I don't need that
many men so she don't go so you know she
don't she didn't [ __ ] see mmm you
know cap [ __ ] Holden fan OHS is this
fist back and [ __ ] and Thanos being like
who are you and he [ __ ] him just like
ah he didn't see the joy of this
[ __ ] with a broken shield busted
body and [ __ ] facing fan OSes entire
army and getting up cuz like [ __ ] it was
half a shield man before the portal
started open so she doesn't have the
same you know mm feel like she saw him
knives out whatnot like that's her Chris
yeah like he wears a sweater yeah to her
he's sweater meat in that movie he's not
he's not Steve Rogers Captain America
sweater meet total sweater me so I says
to her tonight I says do you do you
think like he's attractive as a man in
for her first responses for a Canadian
yeah like why do you think he's from
Canada's Captain America she's like oh
he's not from Canada I said he's a
Masshole he's from Boston like he's a
Massachusetts guy though this thing
we're watching is 7:00 Massachusetts and
I told her when it started I was like oh
he's a producer must be because he's
from Massachusetts and they're doing a
Massachusetts story so Mikey's from
Massachusetts and she goes
yeah yeah it's like yeah he's definitely
attractive and then I had left to come
here tells me she might be flipping the
beam no hugging sweater meat you know
what I'm saying she was paying a lot of
attention and she really every week when
they dropped a new defending Jacob she
was like it's on defending Jacobs on
it's time and I thought she just wanted
a good drama but she might be looking at
old [ __ ] Captain America Chris Evans
she said which one is this and I was
like which what she goes Chris I was
like Oh Evans mmm I said they're all
nice yeah it's like I bet you can do
this all day don't tell her I said that
am i - I sat on a couch next to Captain
America for on The Tonight Show and that
was my one encounter with him and
between you know you chitchat between
the [ __ ] you know sequences this was
going back this was like before he had
done Captain America but they had knows
how Avengers yet war or Winter Soldier
is that the second one yes so you know I
was like oh my god I love you in those
movies man and he goes those movies he
was not like yeah you know and I was
like you doing the next one he's like I
hope but if you know when when at the
end they were like he's done I was like
oh he was done when I met him like and
then my other encounter with him barely
an encounter we were at a radio station
in San Diego for comic-con me and Jay
and you know they brought us in so we're
in the room like before you go into the
rating room so there's another you know
there's a room where everyone's being
interviewed and we're in a ante room
outside that has its own board and so
you could see inside like the window and
he could you know they're talking to
somebody it was Captain America but his
head is fake he's facing them so all
we're seeing his back of his head mmm
but they were like that's Chris Wow
check it out
Jay is like playing with the board and
he goes this is work like yeah like
don't touch it because he
goes into the other station and he
pluses the button goes your wood up cap
and or whatever and Chris Evans turned
around so mad like the maddest face I've
seen on a famous person where you know
like really like you know where we
thought we're gonna get well he thought
he was gonna get beat up I was like I
pointed that I was I got I wouldn't do
that cap I don't say nothing that's my
thing he was like on your left his years
before so he wasn't that clever but
still that he looked at us and then he
when he was done with his interview
because like he was almost toward the
end they'd be kind of left and we didn't
get to be like so sorry for interrupting
your radio thing mr. America yeah feel
max a back from Apple plus two HP oh man
although I can say this defending Jacob
is a good watch there you go eight weeks
and we got there so yeah HBO max like if
you already have if you want to watch a
story about white people that is the
water and that's what we all need right
[Laughter]
that's how we fix America more stories
about white people is for them to just
defend Jacob in fact [ __ ] fat man be on
that's the name of the podcast more
stories about why people what do white
people doing this week marked marks like
it takes all the strength I have go to
that bar and do that blog guess now's
tough when it was called fat man be on
but god damn near impossible now that
we've got this new cover subtitle HBO
max wait you did you get it free or did
I did because AT&T is my cell phone
carrier so here's the question did you
knowing what you now know when I pay for
it yes not now
really I mean if I was if I was shopping
for it and like I want to spend another
15 bucks a month on son
I would wait about a year such a
privileged thing I want to spend another
15 bucks a lot of 15 bucks on a lot of
these [ __ ] things is this
another one for me yeah and like at
present it doesn't seem like they're
ducks are quite in order right you know
like Daffy duck's if you will here Daffy
duck's you duck some bucks or not I'm
mucking right to him up there ducks are
to him oh yeah and I'm sure that like
they are in the process of pulling back
all of the IP that they had licensed out
to other services so that in a year year
and a half two years they will have
everything you want it to be it'll be
like remember Disney Plus launch they're
like hey we don't have you know Black
Panther but it's coming right and then
like a month or two we don't exclusively
have black panther like you can still
see some of this [ __ ] elsewhere right
but now like now it's this is the Disney
Vault yeah and they're getting to the
point where like yeah there's so weird
this is the Disney Vault if you give us
10 bucks you go in into anything you
want would you like to come and see the
gold I keep [ __ ] watching The
Simpsons man and they just put up the
4/3 Simpsons now oh yeah yeah finally
cuz they put up like these old versions
where like squished oh my god it was I
mean it's like oh my god mark the pain
but it was weird watching him where
you're like why oh I remember because
everything went 60 mana
so they fix those yes good well done
yeah he blues yeah [ __ ] yeah finally
the world is better now we could all go
back outside
what what's our next story aside from
you know trashing HBO you know what's
our next and you know again not trashing
but at some point I may end up working
for them so just saying the reality of
it is not trashing I will say not overly
impressed right there I mean thought of
that I love HBO max it's the best thing
ever
I've [ __ ] watched a Looney tune on it
and it was very worth every penny of
that $15 charged me more I says but they
didn't hear me phone doesn't work that
way alright what's next what's next
remember uh remember Doctor Strange that
movie that we liked yes yes [ __ ] love
them remember the director of said
movies God love him
I've had him on a podcast sounds dirty
I've had him on pockets he was a guest
on podcast fir'd - dr. strange lovely
dude yeah he did not come back for the
second Doctor Strange well he's coming
back and then they were like yeah it's
gonna walk through that magic door and
suddenly he was outside right and now we
got a new director and now sam raimi is
doing Doctor Strange and then which is
raising him
he loves Ditko but that being said
something very cool happened for scott
derrickson it did I bet you know where
I'm going with this story how do I
believe me I was couldn't wait to come
and talk about this earlier in the week
then the world exploded yeah but now we
get to finally talk about this is the
neat thing I'm although I want to see I
want to see what your take on it go he's
coming to do labyrinth the sequel
working with the Henson folks
screenwriter Maggie Levin who wrote and
directed into the dark and my valentine
for Hulu so he he's directing and Maggie
Maggie Levin is writing who wrote
labyrinth
oh [ __ ] because that's what I saw when
he was announced there was a minor
outcry on Twitter maybe even a major
outcry but like people were like oh no
labyrinth want to be this guy well
labyrinth is a I didn't know this I've
always loved [ __ ] labyrinth but I try
I watched it with my kid within the last
year as like watch this with me I always
wanted to watch this with you and as we
watched it together I was like yeah I
should have done this with you when you
were not nineteen doesn't quite pan out
but she apparently labyrinth is a big
movie for LGBTQ kids hmm like it's very
meaningful and when Scott was announced
they were like oh no or something like
you it's now my story's not going to be
told or whatever but if it's based on a
script written by Terry Jones wrote it
oh wow I mean really
Andrews telling us a story by Jim Henson
of course and uh Lee Dennis Lee and then
script by Terry Jones one of the Python
one of the founding pythons Wow I don't
know what they're talking about
I mean why were they upset then I don't
know I I thought maybe the first one was
written by like the woman who's a gay
icon or something and that's why they
were like it can't be Scott Derrickson
I was like wait did a movie about magic
it makes sense yeah I get it
but if somebody else wrote it then he's
you know they can't be met that nobody
can be that mad at him I guess a bunch
of people are also mad that they're
doing a labyrinth sequel at all without
David Bowie that's the right that's the
we buried the lead
if you're making a labyrinth dude that's
how much of a buried lead David Bowie is
no longer been with us for a while and
it's been it's been amazing but and also
just died
thank the Lord it is it one day when I
saw labyrinth 2 or they've not calling
it that whatever they call him it I was
like I'll write on I'm all for it and it
never once occurred to me oh my god
David Bowie's not alive
you know I mean it I'll tell you why
because in labyrinth she gets rid of the
bad guy so like he was never coming back
you know what I'm saying like if he came
back I would have been like why'd we go
on that first adventure right unless it
was some like thirty years later [ __ ]
she had her own kid that's probably what
the story is gonna be right it could be
they gotta bring her back yeah you would
think they would they literally have to
otherwise why do it why do they like
seriously somebody got I mean yeah of
course we'll have rude or sad he'll be
he better come back look they all better
come back the only one who's not allowed
to come back as David Bowie for obvious
reasons maybe even better the slide they
can you know CG something so we get a
jerath kind of thing I don't know but
she what is her name Jennifer Connelly
Jennifer Connelly has to [ __ ] come
back even if it's the opening scene
even if she's the mom this time and her
daughter you know gets her little
brother or a little sister [ __ ]
stolen by the Goblin King this thing
writes itself but it really does it's
funny it better be her otherwise like
I'm not going
back in the day I might have said
otherwise we ride but we don't say that
anymore at all
I will be mad if they don't do that who
then who do you who would you prefer
they cast as a new goblin king ah [ __ ]
if you ain't you a harder question than
like dear Kevin and Mark how do we fix
all this
who would I see as a goblin king or
queen at this point okay so it was
alright Bowie he's an icon but remember
this is 1986 Bowie mm-hmm so he's coming
off of like a couple years prior as
modern love and let's dance that album
and all that stuff so he's serious man
like way back in the mainstream so using
that model of a this cat's been around
forever Keanu Reeves Keanu Reeves
whoo interesting well but if you're
going with a musician I mean I'll tell
you my version I'd like to see what
nobody's gonna pay to see it
David Byrne is Jerry like a very quirky
you know [ __ ] he's not spooky as much
as like got interesting lyrics and [ __ ]
who do you got I I would like to see yes
a goblin Queen there we go
Queen played by Jennifer Connelly
there's a writer I'm gonna split with
you on that though it's a good idea but
like no you ever seen her go bad in a
movie I've seen her do lots of things
and record in with a dream yeah but like
always still he kind of felt bad for her
yeah as she fell down that hole I
haven't seen snowpiercer yet but she
says she plays the plays the bad Tilda
Swinton kind of part no not quite but I
think Wheatley different from the movie
snowpiercer
I haven't seen it couldn't tell you
yeah I I'm not I think that's a cool
idea on paper but like at the end of the
day I don't know if she was the bad guy
would we know it the whole time or they
you know pull a mask at the end screw
stuff it would've got away with it if it
wasn't for you puppets I think you know
what the whole time I think somehow I
don't want to see your movie then if
they threw it at me at the last second
I'd be like oh oh but I'm the whole
movie I'm like wait she's the bad guy I
don't buy it that's the voice of Peter
Parker's suit or if I can't if I can't
have Bowie and you won't let me have
Jennifer Connelly no you can have
whatever you want more particularly this
weekend anything you won't think you up
Jennifer Connelly I'll get you to forgot
her Range Rover
Jemaine Clement Oh from if flight of the
conchords because he does the best Bowie
Oh does it really he does a very good
Bowie to the point where he was above
that token let's get rich little to be
[ __ ] jerk if you can dig up and we're
digging up ten people let's get polar
zoom good boy
go back to square one and that kids is
how the studio's work the circle of life
you guys I just read yours on inside
yeah yeah that never occurred to me and
stuff let me see whose sting hi all
right oh I got a pitch pitch it Eddie
Murphy is the goblin king he'd be funny
yeah oh yeah you let him do that once
that's one of them he gets one of those
per picture um maybe fun JC kam JC kam
he's gotta thought you go musician again
you go Adam Lambert cut back to us [ __ ]
you know I don't who is that I don't
know he's he's now the the singing voice
of Queen he was the voice of Queen he
was runner-up on America
idle a few million iterations ago fair
enough
well obviously I'm that idea didn't get
much support from me yeah only because
I'm completely ignorant that was the
Internet in me just responding I'm a gut
reaction Andrew you got a pitch man you
hit the Internet at your disposal you're
gonna like really deep dive down Janelle
Monae oh I don't watch that she's good
yeah I'd take that I like her in
interviews - I just watched an interview
with her I forget where it was she's
pushing homecoming so was that young
like what she's pushing um home cuz
she's in the second season of homecoming
the Amazon sort of war vet sci-fi
conspiracy thing is that right yeah
Julie Roberts was in season one and she
took over like an anthology kind of
thing wait so that was isn't that made
by the guy that did Sam s man yeah yeah
so wait that the Julia Roberts show that
she did with mr. robot yeah is no longer
the Julia Roberts show with mr. robot
it's Janelle Monae with mr. robot yes
[ __ ] odd the alert [ __ ] on this show
and it's kind of genre is it I believe
it is the first year it feels it feels a
little like spy-fi government conspiracy
yeah like that movie she was in years
ago conspiracy theory yes bringing it
back to yes always alright next always
next story
let's get Denzel Washington to play the
Goblin King so we could get Denzel
Washington easier to being get Victor
Garber apparently the [ __ ] that'd be
amazing
yeah but him as the as the goblin king a
real serious take on him do not ever in
your entire life take that baby from me
at one point they take the baby he's
like slap the table from Malcolm X
alright what other stories we got um hey
do you remember the guy who played
Superman for a while Henry Cavill you
know what's your fellow yes
to your witcher fellow that's for sure
but I always think of Henry Cavill as
Henry the eighth's young buddy from that
show I loved was Jonathan to dryers yes
the tutors he was his buddy man I
remember when they were like that guys
playing Superman I was like I like that
guy on that [ __ ] he lived tutors down he
did two doors down right next to Dolly
Parton as for all our country and
western fans out there it turns out that
he is not done playing the Man of Steel
what I know is this a Jeb Schneider cut
Justice League um it is unclear like
it's the well there's no Man of Steel
sequel in the works we're hearing says
the Internet HBO Mac show probably not
but that he's in talks to her prizes why
not probably not he's a Netflix show why
couldn't he be on a Superman HBO I mean
I would love them to do Superman does
not say no they got a Superman and Lois
show on the CW but they could also do
what others who'd mentioned they want it
was three more three more but he's in
negotiations to reprise his role in the
Warner Brothers DC Universe it
nobody's entirely sure how yet even
though it could come a couple of
different ways probably for the Snyder
verse to return for the Snyder could put
him well remember how he was almost in
Shazam they could put him in Shazam
Shazam - is it working they're working
on that no black black Adam Adam you
know because we wouldn't like to see
[ __ ] Superman fight Black Adam that'd
be cool you know and maybe it's the kids
a traditionally black Adam and Shazam
Captain Marvel are that the you know the
guys who they fight each other
but in a world and but he should come in
and like help out right or if you needed
to like because she's am as they've been
playing him is not necessarily the sort
of Shazam that you're gonna play like
Black Adam feels like it's a real
villain story yeah
and Shazam feels like it's a like kids
movie and I'm not sure if the Zack Levi
Dwayne Johnson pairing gives you the
tone that you want so you could swap out
Superman for Shazam
excellent point if you wanted to do that
or there's Aquaman that's that's Shazam
- Shazam gets killed in the first two
minutes
[Laughter]
we couldn't do another Man of Steel
every cavils like you want to be back
the cost Bush Shazam this is amening
yeah he's coming back I'm all for that I
think it's good I thought it was sad
when he was like oh we're pardon ways
when they couldn't work out a deal for
Shazam because he at the end of spoilers
at the end of Shazam yeah it's cute
little bit we're [ __ ] Superman comes
to have lunch in a in the school
cafeteria mm-hmm and you know it's a s
on a suit and [ __ ] ah but I'd only ever
see this much of it that's it so you
know it would have you know if they
could have ironed whatever out that
would have been a nice thing for him to
pop up and and stuff so hopefully
they'll continue with more of that I
mean it seems as if for reasons that
escape me Superman is proving
troublesome for Warner Brothers yeah I
mean these [ __ ] writers that can't
write Superman scripts I don't get it
what I was one of them in 1996 uh yeah
it said historically writers always go
like it's hard to write for him he's
like because he's all-powerful he's like
Jesus and stuff right but you know I
don't know come on man they be dude in
comics for like 75 years or more and
they could this pick one of those
stories like I remember when I first
went to Warner Brothers like in 96 and I
met with Basel II Wanek who went on to
like produce movies I think he produce
Argo I think his name I saw it on or
something like and all that John Wick's
he did he just John Wick's I mean I
haven't spoken as [ __ ] in like
24 years yeah so I like since like I got
that job but he was you know I went to
meet with something about about
something unrelated and I asked about
Superman because I was like what else
are you working on he pitched maybe
juice goes Hawaiian and the second one
was the architects of fear which was
based on the Outer Limits episode that
Alan Moore
used in Watchmen mm-hmm for the we're
gonna build the thing and then teleport
it to a place um the script was amazing
I I was just thinking about the other
day I'm like who wrote that script they
never made the movie but it like in 1996
they were like see what you could do
with this would you like to rewrite this
I brought it back to dazzle Evonik and I
was like no make this or don't because
it's an 80 million dollar art film like
it was so smart and [ __ ] it's it was
almost like now I think about a script
that was sent from the future to 1996
because it was so [ __ ] ahead of its
time and stuff so I brought it back and
I was like you don't need to fix this
script like you either make it or don't
but like do not [ __ ] monkey with this
this is like perfect like it took I
remember that episode of [ __ ] Outer
Limits and [ __ ] like that this took the
concept and like ran with it made it
something [ __ ] beautiful smart human
you went through the story for those who
don't know is like a bunch of scientists
want to come up with an alien to send to
earth and that would scare all the
countries into uniting and stuff but in
order to create an alien they take a
human being who volunteers to undergo
drastic surgery to invert him and make
him not look like a human so that he
could show up and pretend to be this
alien and stuff so that was like the
black and white version the [ __ ]
feature version that I read was like
take that notion and put it in the hands
of like a genius writer again I can't
remember who got this [ __ ] script but
it was incredibly [ __ ] intricate and
powerful and moving about a human giving
up their humanity to save all of
humanity really great stuff and I'm like
and you want the guy who made mall rats
take a shot so while we were there he
was talking about Superman oh my god can
I read that and stuff and he said yeah
I'm he gave me the script and I read it
and stuff and I've told the Superman
story zillion times but the point of it
is this when I went back in I was like
why don't you just I said this script is
don't make this movie I said whatever
you do just don't make this Superman
movie like why don't you just go to DC
comics and ask Mike Carlin he's the head
of the Superman group what story can we
do hey do you want to write a scrip like
these guys write this [ __ ] all the time
and in 1996 they were like that's comic
books accountable guys you know they're
not movie guys it's a different world
now very much a slightly different but
back then there was this dismissive like
they couldn't do this it's like they do
it every week they've solved the problem
Superman title every week and they keep
telling stories about the most powerful
character in the world and [ __ ] and they
find problems for like bro kryptonite
like that's all you need but I sort of
like this idea of Superman being for the
dze you what the Hulk is for the MCU yes
which is the Hulk doesn't get his own
yes not his own movie since the the ed
Norton version yes because they actually
Marvel doesn't have the rights I believe
to his solo hope the solo rights
belonged to Universal don't you know and
they don't want to after the last
experience universe the way I've always
heard it Marvel like they're like we
don't meet - yeah as long as we can
stick him in any movie we want but if we
call it the Hulk if he's the titular
character then Universal is involved
then they gets a so they're like but
otherwise we could put him in any movie
and use him just fine and they still
feel he doesn't warrant his own
standalone yeah and like that they could
do that with Superman I'm all for it if
they can find you know the the slot for
him is as the very very strong number 2
or the you know sometimes comic relief I
mean I think that you can do all that
stuff with Superman if you need to fight
with that same bug but I think so I
think he's just kind of like five
minutes of fame man let's be on our show
hey we worked hard to get here yeah so
yeah and also like they had said in the
in the Snyder Justice League that like
we're not planning to get any of the
original actors back for reshoots
yeah well I've read that story after we
talked last week after or whenever we
did our show the one where we had been
on yeah there was a
you know report the next day that like
well now calm down it's not everything
it's you're not getting like and they
calm down was to the audience nineteen
Zack Snyder your there's no reshoots
with actors now that doesn't mean there
won't necessarily be reshoots you know
you could a lot of those characters had
outfits so you could do that you know
you could if the reshoots with the
actors becomes the real actors becomes
expensive because their contract is dead
they would have to make a new contract
this is a completely new project and
that's generally when the agents would
swoop in and be like alright well if
you're doing it again full freight he
gets this she gets that you know move on
so by saying like no actors they could
you know if needs be if Zack had to
finish a sequence you know I mean they
don't need Ben for Batman they need a
person in a Batman suit so it's
conceivable he might there's wiggle room
even if he's not getting those lead
actors bad per se for action sequences
and who knows I'm sure they would I mean
I don't I don't know anything so I'm
like I'm sure they would but I don't
imagine they're all tight with him they
seem like and if he was like can you
come back and Elyse to like a Bruce
Wayne thing or a Diana thing without
putting on the outfits or whatever who
knows I don't know I don't know that
world well alright but or maybe they
will come back maybe they're in
negotiations maybe it's like listen you
know well [ __ ] we'll pay your Freight
nice it's a good week with you guys back
and we can shoot all the dialogue
character stuff that we didn't get Mike
if they're gonna spend 40 million on
this like in for a penny in for a pound
right and so maybe that's part of this
negotiation maybe there will be further
negotiations for for Ben and for for gal
like I think that all of these things
are up in the air wouldn't surprise me
if that was part of it do you think
somewhere down the road of might pop up
again I think so I mean I I agree in as
much as again he seems very tight with
his cast mm-hmm
and you know I would say public support
is a hundred percent on his side
something that none of those cats were
used to when Justice League came out
you know so easy to rally around that
flag and if he needs them and there's a
Justice League won't they answer the car
otherwise have comics lied to me mark
yeah I know like the Justice buddies the
Justice Fairweather friend yes my mom
will let me do the justice coasters
sorry who is this
no I'm unfamiliar with it the Justice
ellipses just the three dots in the text
are you up you up you want to play no
I'm sure they'll come back
yeah and that's also another nice
announcement for him like one month from
now like we got to boost these
subscriptions like bands coming back we
decided stop giving it away for free we
buy this Oh other places news happens
yeah we're sick when I think I've ever
had good places of news mark lost the
power I just really just lost my for a
second grammar apparently Universal I
think emboldened by the invisible man's
performance both critically and
financially which again like holds up
yeah very much dude clever cheap movie
cheap also being the key word here yeah
not an expensive movie especially when
Tom Cruise's mummy costs you know pretty
penny and stuff so the next time they're
like here's a modern monster it's seven
million dollars late did below now who's
the new monster the Wolfman is the new
monster okay
played by the Gosling really yes I'm
going to drive around in a car and look
dour most of the movie I think so who's
gonna have like a Wolfman on the back of
his jacket I love Ryan Gosling so I'm
I'm all for it but you know it better
not be like some kind of quiet
meditation like see people jumping
around I wanna see transformation be
great if they brought Rick Baker back
like Rick Baker man are you kidding me
like we do this with CG now but come on
let him have
give it to him I mean he don't even want
it we had Rick on the show tired I don't
want to do that [ __ ] is hard yeah but
stay gonna make up is fun dealing with
the studios are hard could you imagine
if you created a thing like that you
know I had Joe Alves this week SModcast
I interviewed Joe Alves who created jaws
and it's a great episode because I just
fan out and listen and ask questions and
he tells he was there dude he was there
he's the first on the vineyard he's
hired before Steven Spielberg Wow
we need a shark Joe it's his it's David
Brown who worked with them on Sugarland
Express who was also with Steven but
they before they even brought Steven on
before they bought the book Wow he
reached out to Joe Alves and be like
could you build the shark let's see some
shark drawings and so he started sending
shark drawings and Joe was like you know
he's got them in the book he's got this
book called designing Jaws hardcover
books gorgeous but the early drawings
like that he did in 1972 he's like I
remember the day and it was 1972 he got
the call it wasn't like it is today
where you'd be like shark google shark
and you'll get a zillion images like
sharks weren't a thing until Jaws right
so he drew sharks that looked like
whales in some places because he's like
you know it's a story of a giant 25-foot
shark so some of the sharks look as a
bunch of different character studies but
like he then got in touch with an
ichthyologist who was then like walking
him through like no they look like this
and bringing the nose in and [ __ ] and
like and then he goes on to create the
shark that defines what sharks look like
for an entire generation so much so that
when I saw documentary footage of sharks
I was like that's not what a great white
shark looks like they're very large and
they keep their mouths open all the time
it was fascinating man but that dude was
there for like the building of it and
stuff like that how do I get to him uh
Rick Baker werewolf so Rick Baker man
likes just like could you imagine doing
a thing and that's what my point I was
gonna be like he came up with the makeup
effect of how to turn somebody into the
american werewolf in london and those
effects when that movie came out
everyone was like this is [ __ ] nuts
this is madness it's not like dissolves
like they did with lon chaney it's like
you're watching this [ __ ] transform
and [ __ ] they would never do that again
because it would be too time-consuming
and too expensive and that dude had to
create an entire [ __ ] art form that
is now no longer used just like Joe
Alves all the [ __ ] they did to make that
shark you would never do today you don't
even have to even something as simple as
this it's blew my mind so he works with
Spielberg on Close Encounters as well so
you know Close Encounters in the script
it says a weird mountain and he's taxed
with going out to find that weird
mountain so he's like I went out I drove
all over the country because you can't
just google weird mountain you've
literally got to go find the weird
mountain and in Wyoming
I guess we're devil towers he's like we
were driving and like you could see it
in the distance and it's weird because
it's it's like in the middle of nowhere
he's like but then you go down a hill
and it disappears you don't think
anything of it you come up a hill and
suddenly it is right in front of you and
it's how it grows as you come up that
hill that's so impressive and so he had
a 35-millimeter camera he went up in a
helicopter hired a helicopter and shot
footage of Devil's Tower and brought it
home and to Steven to be like is this
the weird mountain and they were like
that is kind of like how [ __ ] up is
that man when you think about like that
image of Devil's Tower there's on the
poster like you know maybe maybe people
don't [ __ ] with Close Encounters as much
as they used to back in the day and [ __ ]
but like an iconic [ __ ] movie we've
gotta me award-winning movie and [ __ ]
that image that that mountain is
everything just like that shark in Jaws
is everything and you know both of those
movies were
I was like Steven Spielberg and
rightfully so always the director but
literally it begins with [ __ ] Joe
Alves going like I'll find the weird
mountain because that's all it said in
the script a weird mouth that's the part
that not that Joe Alves isn't you know a
[ __ ] miracle worker for finding
Devil's Tower but how you even write
that script without knowing that that's
the thing crazy like it's a weird
mountain like but it's you would have
imagined somebody been like oh I've been
to Wyoming I saw this weird [ __ ]
mountain so I wrote it they call it
Devil's Tower bah blah but this was this
a shot in the dark like weird Mountain
yeah he comes back with not worse more
this is weird right their faces look
like aliens could be have done this
right I'll do you one better nowadays
you'd write weird Mountain and someone
would digitally build it I wouldn't go
to the weird mountain
that's [ __ ] up like Steven even have
like a like a time life book of weird
mountains it is like you know what that
one you didn't need to
he had Joe Alves the parents on SModcast
he's weak he was he was the first human
Google like Joe he was he was a dude
that just crazy man I like when I I knew
he'd built the shark or you designed the
shark was built by somebody else but the
I did not know about Devil's Tower and I
was that blew my hair back where I'm
like you're responsible for the 70s like
it was all you Joe
you're a good man Joe Alves he's old for
you what else we got um well first let's
finish the wolfman's oh yeah I forgot I
was so excited
sources say the Gosling would play an
anchor man who gets infected and becomes
a werewolf fake news fake news the
script who would hang News thank nice
thank you
the script which is written by Lauren
sugar bloom and Rebecca Angelou so
ladies two ladies is described as having
a fad that evokes network and
Nightcrawler not the BAMF version but
James yeah thank you thank you for
clarifying because it was like amp is
back sweet all right well yeah man it's
the end of that story so wait when they
say like Nightcrawler and [ __ ] so that
mean he don't really turn into a wolf
man
um I think he does but there I think
they're more talking about kind of like
the crazy Go Go news version of modern
society where this guy is a you know
maybe like a Morton Downey jr. would
have been if he was a modern newsman
who's directing I don't have one yet hey
hey now hey Universal see this face
don't hire it you don't want a piece of
this see this face it's gonna pay to see
your movie
speaking of universal horrors and
visible man the guy who wrote and
directed Invisible Man
Leigh Whannell yeah wrote that movie was
it upgrade yes yes it's like a movie
he's getting a TV show
oh yeah you know what you could set that
would totally lend itself to an ongoing
premise yeah yeah I mean the film is a
fun [ __ ] movie it was inexpensive as
well he made it very cheap that's his
jam which is you know I will take these
high concept ideas and find a way to do
them for incredibly reasonable budgets
he's ruining it for the rest of us I
know and it was about this guy whose
wife gets killed and he gets sort of
paralyzed and there's some hyper
billionaire dude who comes from this as
they listen I can through this magic
technology I can give you the use of
your body back but there's gonna be a
price to pay and it goes wrong but he
basically turns into like Robocop on a
hunt for revenge where his body you know
is somewhat self-aware and you turn like
it's it's just super [ __ ] core a less
agreeable six million dollar man yes
which now for nothing could have been
the reboot for that maybe that's what
they should call this show the less
agreeable it's an awfully long time to
put on a poster but what was the title
of our new pug yes more stories about
white people first right up there at
that time agreeable six million dollar
man
Amanda dolls for that they're gonna be
great yeah look through the eye of the
far less agreeable six million dollar
man yeah but um Blum house TV along with
universal content producers UCP are
producing the adaptation there's a few
mm house movies that could easily be
turned into TV shows I'm sure they're
working hard at it now
the purge a TV show yeah it was a TV
show recently canceled did they cancel
it very did two seasons they did two
seasons the purge and they canceled it
in the same press releases they canceled
Treadstone which I worked on your old
bureau babe so how many seasons they get
at one one season at Red's down
catastrophic the expensive show really
oh yeah because they shot they were
meant to go more than one season it was
meant to be an ongoing affair but you
know the ratings were never at all of
that strong and it was crazy expensive
like they shot in Prague did they ever
get to mention Jason Bourne or no um I
don't believe they ever do sorry I
remember yes it I think we called him
and that's what it was called yeah the
child if only you'd call that the child
which that show would have been a hit
the babe the people to power what power
there we go there's your labyrinth -
baby Yoda we already did it sorry guys
it's all about how the Goblin King
steals baby Yoda from Jon Favreau and
Dave Filoni and they're like we're
[ __ ]
what do we do now I gotta go into
labyrinth to get a mountain [ __ ] have
you watched any of the Disney gallery
documentary about the making of the
mandalorian no behind the scenes yeah
it's a it's pretty [ __ ] badass
I mean the first episode is there's five
up now I think the first episode it's
just like hey it's a roundtable for the
most part it's it's Favreau sitting with
a bunch of people involved in everything
first ones like directors and so they
talked to dinner for five right it's
very much that you know Dave Filoni and
like a Chow and like all the gang who
put together the show and well Bryce was
in Bryce Dallas Howard and when the
fourth episode is all about the
technology and it's all about a shared a
video wall yeah the day they walked you
through the volume and how you know
Favreau was instrumental in sort of
pushing them towards that it's okay we
did some of this on
Jungle Book and here's what it did
incredibly well but here's what was hard
like you couldn't really just anything
on the fly because it's all previz and
it's all you know just changing lighting
was a day-long affair and
by the experience of Lion King or
because everything is digital you had
more control and you could you know and
then he got the idea of talking to two
game engine designers that makes sense
mm-hmm my guys who are like rendering
real-time footage in like
photo-realistic fashion and they amp
that version up to the volume they call
it which is like this giant room it's
the size of a soundstage where like the
floors and the ceiling and the walls are
all [ __ ] TV screens the giant screens
I've seen him I've been in the room with
him when I was working on Kingdom
Keepers for Disney Plus before they
killed it they called me and they were
like we want to show you the patek that
you're gonna be using right and they
brought me into a room and had the wall
set up and it was insane like you know
once you looked off the wall you were
like oh it's a giant [ __ ] TV screen
and once it went off it was like oh it's
a giant monitor check once they turned
it on if you tunnel visioned it and you
know blinders it you were in this
post-industrial [ __ ] kind of Blade
Runner looking set that went deep so
that's the tech that they use you could
program it yeah to have your backgrounds
happening while movies happening totally
and it's dynamic in camera or it's like
if you decide you want to move it here
at the background will shift that was
the most even on my phone I have my cell
phone and they were like go ahead shoot
it and everywhere I went with my phone
it shifted like the perspective of a
camera like it all [ __ ] moved it was
insane amazing yeah
and so that's what the fourth episode is
all about and it's it's remarkable like
a thing that you would not have thought
possible five years ago and it will and
I think especially now that we're in a
world where we have to quarantine actors
and the word medication she means a lot
of that you know and fav even said and
you'd be talking like that Cathy Kennedy
a bunch of the ilm guys and and they
were all again none of this is
proprietary this is all like kind of
open source software like we're not we
didn't we didn't build anything that you
couldn't build at home or yourself or in
another studio and we just put stuff
together to have been put together
before but if you want to do this
everybody else in the world you can
and that idea of like oh this might be
how production gets up and running for
big-budget movie for big-budget movies
or like even [ __ ] TV I mean
mandalorian like they spend I'm a
big-budget
alright yeah I mean I don't know ain't
gonna help out [ __ ] clerks three yeah
I don't know if you need to do it [ __ ]
boy that could be his store looks deep
when you walk over here it moves like
Jesus's eyes a snack perspective on the
walls change but yeah I think it could
very well be revolutionary in the way
they shoot both big-time movies and like
big-time TV shows maybe what is you
working on the card
you think they'll wind up I mean it's
possible you know there's a show that's
like you know not like a we're going to
Eliam planet you can do that real well
let's show you how yeah you should watch
that on the Disney Plus if you get a
chance if you like they made along the
making of what's called the Disney
Gallery : the man like kid has been
bugging me for a week she's like watch
the Imagineering story it will make you
cry and I was like I don't want like I
don't need help crying yeah believe me
upper here yeah there's one thing your
father does well in this life it's
crying I got this I am I admit I was
little I didn't want to watch it because
like a lot of our kingdom keepers thing
was like grounded in the Imagineering
folk so I was like I don't know it's
honestly probably why I didn't watch
that documentary too because I'm like
they're gonna show that wall yes and
it's gonna remind me that like we almost
made a gigantic [ __ ] off the show for
Disney that had every [ __ ] piece of
IP in it like every character so close
yeah so close damn it
but you know what more stories about
white people that's what we just had
kids up next
yes Fraggle Rock down in Fraggle Rock
yes I think we'll close it out with a
little good news is in other Muppet news
before we even dive into that did you
get a taste of
Elmo's not too late show or whatever I
didn't did you
adorable is it really really adorable I
I've had enough Elmo from my entire life
but just in terms of it's not just amo
it's the entire Sesame Street cast here
my best ex is my best description it is
the Muppet Show but with the Sesame
Street characters okay so like they make
it work there in entertainment and Elmo
has to host the show early because Elmo
goes to bed at 7:30 come on that's
[ __ ] adorable to dorms really sweet
maybe I will I will I will look for
something I want to watch on HBO max not
find it and then watch the Elmo show get
a bottle of vodka sorry it kick back and
watch the other show like a grim bitter
old man take her to marks like sell out
a little bit early do you Elmo used to
be cool welcome to a show in a bar Elmo
yeah where where's Elmo not here
although he could easily work here we've
got like and a bar that he somebody
could stick them up yeah come on up the
art of puppetry
that's my puppetry book stick them up
yeah that's nice back to Fraggle Rock
practive Fraggle Rock a new thing
happening somewhere a new version of
Fraggle Rock got a series order at Apple
wait it's not already happening they
have a series of shorts like a bunch of
Fraggle Rock shorts that are currently
up there so now they're like we're gonna
make whole shows yeah
Fraggle Rock Rock on shorts which
recently debuted on Apple Plus but now
they're doing a full on like a whole
Fraggle Rock puppets or CG puppets back
to puppets back to [ __ ] puppets hell
yeah Doozers included oh yeah can't do
these without the Doozers man probably
not the old gentleman who lived upstairs
right well let's see it will reunite the
original stars gobo red Boober mokey
Wembley and uncle travelling Matt OH
remember travelling man but still the
guy who lived upstairs no probably not
that's a little like he had a dog though
remember they had the dog sometimes it
was a real dog sometimes it was a puppet
dog shifty I mean they were handsome
they were like it's an it's an animal
let's replace it with a [ __ ] puppet
give somebody a job
we'll give three guys a job it's just
adorable anyway I'm are I'm all for it
yeah Who am I gonna stand in the way of
Fraggle Rock no no no it has to be joy
not only joy God more the more joy we
can find the better and we hope that you
found a little bit of joy tonight ladies
and gentlemen because that's all the
news that's all the news and we're not
doing questions fair enough JC looked at
the questions and was like shuffle off
to Buffalo no more questions it was a
sad day mark and it's been a sad few
days and as we learned it's you know
it's pretty much it's a little bit of
sad for you every damn day it sounds
like almost to some degree but boy oh
boy coming here was a nice little
respite it always is just a moment and
now we go go back into it and stuff put
on our our literal and figurative masks
indeed and head back out into the world
and stuff but thanks to the audience for
saying yeah do it otherwise that
probably would have been sitting home
just watching the news obsessively and
yeah it was worth doing it was worth -
for sure a smart man said we can come
what do you say read that tweet again
I mean you wrote it can you say mark you
just content to watch JC quote you say
the words JC my portable notable speak
the words speak them loud I think I
might be I think it might be important
to do a show addressing both the things
that are tearing us apart as well as the
things that bring us together do you
feel like we accomplished that tonight I
think we did I think we did man thank
you as always to the man sit into my
life without whom there
no show mr. mark barnard tonight that
absolutely would have been the case mmm
if Mark was like no let's not do it it
wouldn't happen stuff but stay home and
watch the news more I you know honestly
like yesterday I shot a short film so I
was off mmm the Internet and the news
for like 12 hours straight and then
whenever that we wrapped it like 1:00 in
the morning and stuff and then I was
like I'm gonna sit down smoke a joint
and see what's happening in the world no
no no no no no this is this was welcome
this was nice as nice as it can be in
times like this look out for each other
everybody remember your humanity more
importantly remember everyone else's
humanity I'd hate to be this person and
stuff and it's very easy for me to say
but we are all in this together
all we have is each other that's it so
let's let's be a lot better to each
other maybe that's where it starts like
Mark said that and all the financial
stuff with Bruce Wayne and whatnot a lot
of infrastructure yes really really I
mean billionaires stops wasting your
money on bat pods on bat bikes bat
anything I mean I get it Elon Musk you
want to throw people in a space I
understand but maybe the people here
could also use a little bit from a bone
yes there it is ladies and gentlemen
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the scum and villainy Cantina thanks to
JC for letting us in thanks to Andrew
for making it happen there's no Andrew
shot you'll see notice he gets his own
dedicated camp gets a disembodied voice
he's in a dark Harry Potter under the
stairs little corner where he yells out
facts and changes cam just wait for
somebody give him a sock I can finally
have his freedom
[Laughter]
Toby's free is that what it's predicated
on is he owned of the owns a clothing
he's deserving of freedom and so Harry
Potter gives him not a shirt not like
pants for some dignity give him a
[ __ ] sock and Bobby's like
over the moon monster gave me so we
write that [ __ ] da begins a [ __ ] ring
or a condom something that is even close
there's just him like the [ __ ] Red
Hot Chili Peppers with that give it away
give it away give it away now give it
away give it away give it away
dumpy you don't wear it like that you
can't tell me what to do anymore I gotta
stop I'm free
Dobby swings low suck my sock dick oh
he's gonna get some wet oh good lord
yeah you're welcome Jake hey oh you just
improved her [ __ ] man
where were you when she was drafting out
with her in the pub what could this
health do you'd be like you can put a
sock on his dick number one just like
the Red Hot Chili Peppers
it's Dobies big dick Bobby says when
Bobby's ready to shoot now that was
Dobby in Boogie Nights I think it marks
punchy or overtired or maybe having a
stroke
but was actually brilliant that's your
da bein stuck in Hindi [ __ ] Boogie
Nights
Dobby Nights is the movie I didn't know
I wanted to see HBO max Dobby Knights
lesser words
Dobby nights anthology is Dobby hitting
all the like seven deadly sins Christian
it's Tommy learning Dobby learning to be
like a human yes totally so he has to
face all the [ __ ] that we face so it's
like a coming-of-age story but with a
house-elf with a sock on his dick and he
has to learn to wear clothes and [ __ ]
like that this thing writes itself
Larry and he like turns his back on
being a human it's like I'm just wearing
the shock I read this suits anymore
that's right that's how I and he learns
love Abu Dhabi Dobby only needs his [ __ ]
shocked look that's a better name that
will make people do ninh Dhabi in the
[ __ ] sock hey watch that show holy [ __ ]
JK Rowling presents the Dhabi in the
[ __ ] sock
[ __ ] kiss and then the sock oh
yeah of course it does suck you off why
would you take it off I know you can't
come off
well not off my vagina dentata and just
like you know she said I think she sat
on the internet shouldn't say in the
books but like you know people ask her
questions JK Rowling be like well
where's all the wizards poo or whatever
she gave him an answer she was just like
they've did it all match they don't have
sewer systems it just they vanish it of
course they did I mean why not they make
food appear so why wouldn't you make the
food this or like that dude to come to
the alley behind the bar loads out the
back door man I know we shouldn't be
bitching about that but still we almost
stepped in human poop but yeah it's like
the [ __ ] job for the worst wizard like
what's your job oh I I get rid of
Dementors me how am I in the bank at
Gringotts what do you do i do separate
all of the feces yeah like oh thank you
number one
thank you for your service yes thank you
one thank you for the number two but
number two you where do they all go if
each one is responsible like apparently
it's a spell you learn like right away
where it's just like you never have to
deal with [ __ ] again hmm so you drop it
you squat you drop yeah and then it
magics someplace is it going to a
different dimension where they're like
what the [ __ ] maybe that's where that
[ __ ] in the interdimensional Hogwarts
[ __ ] is awkward [ __ ] awkward [ __ ] is the
two word [ __ ] title of the review of
our Dobby and the [ __ ] sock show
Hogwarts [ __ ]
I bet you didn't think we were gonna
[ __ ] fanfiction rights of God to him
Harry Potter story did you it's like we
couldn't help ourselves like we ended
the show like kind of its dignity like
what have you put a sock on his dick
yeah but like no even like literally
ended the show with like alright guys
take care of each other be good to each
other
what if Dobby wore a [ __ ]
so that's believe me right we're gonna
get a home we're gonna get off this show
go to the Internet and that's when all
the hate is gonna come they're like they
were so close to getting out clean man
is that all I see Dobby
they said some real [ __ ] about some real
[ __ ] and then went off the rails
although if somebody wants to send any
portion of this to JK Rowling loved it
yeah she would love it to kind of
imagine she'd get a chuckle out of it
she might correct us with a tweet that
would never happen for these reasons and
then write the mythology right there
right like Bobby's house elves turns out
unix all of them really oh [ __ ] that's
darkness you took it in - I wasn't
that's like the black mirror version of
our show where suddenly Dhabi's got no
dick - put a sock on no [ __ ] force is
that like oh god this [ __ ] rides itself
the HBO max you want to go max we got
the ideas we got it then there's a scene
of him in the mirror like at the end of
[ __ ] Boogie Nights this big dick but
now there's no dick at all just the
stuff and he goes in and cleans the
house again now because he wants to know
not because he asked you and that's the
that's the growth the dub he wants - yes
he takes pride I wouldn't honestly I
wouldn't have thought about Dobby for
like 10 years I'm so glad you brought
him up somebody go home and rock my wife
with a bunch of Dobby jokes she's gonna
be like where'd this come from oh you
know I'm well-read I'm literary man in
the world discover some [ __ ] wait a
second you just talked about it on your
show artists jokes oh my god they're all
mark Bernardin's jokes yeah and this
show has been mark Bernards joke please
our third title thanks for hanging out
with us in your own fat man beyond for
fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark
Barnard tune in next time same bat time
same bat Channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith be
peaceful folks I held up 350 he's useful
you